I'm worried about Ronnie leaving I heard
you guys talking about let me yes cuz
you were a guy who grew up in Vegas
Ronny basically like I asked him off the
air I said Ron are you really gonna
retire and he said no no no he goes
listen I'm gonna be 71 when you retire
it's time for me to go you know what am
I supposed to do just work the rest of
my life I should have it a couple of
years where I can hang I think you
should stay here I think you need to
stay what Howard isn't that like don't
you feel like some kind of sworn duty to
say now he's saying his fame is getting
oh stop it that it's getting a little
much that's what he told one of our PA
yeah no I know how Johnny Depp feels
Ronny and there's bops my late door
garage yeah and there's some [ __ ] on the
other um I don't even know oh yeah it's
a scorpion my birth sign and your new
school teacher and my school yeah it'd
be funny if your [ __ ] would suddenly
come out riding puppy do you have a [ __ ]
who took my eye